bank rate says as of September 22
average debt among consumers is 96 000
what happens when you tie the center
does that include the car yeah that
includes car house 96
000 so 100 Grand basically yeah you that
the average American owes in debt
correct including the mortgage yes
correct yeah 100 Grand I'd like to know
what it is without the Mortgage Debt
Clock has debt per taxpayer 250 000 so
you're now looking at three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars essentially in
debt in total right how does this tie
into the national debt how do we dig
ourselves out of this hole does how does
this like are they non-sequiturs does it
not like can you not compare them what
does it do to the dollar like how do we
dig ourselves about this I have very
strong feelings Tom you can go there
there are two rules of two schools of
thought on there and the first is
we're set for a massive economic reset
someday because you just can't stop this
and the other side is no you don't have
to worry about it deficit spending you
just print I mean take a look at what
um what we just did as a nation and
printing 40 of the total currency and
searches the modern monetary Theory
right that's right modern monetary
Theory says it really doesn't matter
um you just you're just going to print
and you're going to grow and you know
nothing is nothing is ever going to be
more debt and value than than the land
and resources of your country which is
it's kind of dangerous so I I think
we're seeing
a gridlock Washington with the two
schools are unable to control the other
one is we're just going to print and we
get deficits look we have to go back to
Clinton to find a president that came
closest to having a balanced budget and
when everybody hears when you hear about
balance budget amendment what that means
is the government spends on defense and
ships and bombs and national parks and
all the stuff that we do and jails and
prisons and all that what they spent was
exactly what came in from income taxes
corporate taxes and tariffs and other
supplemental taxes that we have the
taxes that came in they spent
it's been since the Clinton
Administration where we were even
freaking close to a balanced budget so
we are spending can I get my opinion on
this so and then Tom he's asking for
Solutions so can we do anything about
this that's that's what zero okay your
point is I don't think in a gridlock
sorry in a gridlock Washington I don't
think you're ever going to be able to
control it how can I get a balanced
budget go ahead what do you think can be
done about this
I mean I I will tell you my issue but I
want to hear yours first I'm going to
give I'll be the heel in this situation
because I know you're going to come up
with a solution so I know that you're
going to have something but I say this
all the time there's things that matter
and there's things that you can control
where you should focus are were those
two things intersect does our national
debt matter of course like if you look
at this chart for longer than two
seconds your head's gonna explode with
all the numbers and up and down
but at the end it's a very selfish
answer you cannot worry about this you
can only worry about what you can do
with your own household now granted are
there different policies that you can
vote for are there different politicians
that you can vote for but when's the
last time Clinton was in office 2000 so
the last 22 years nobody's done [ __ ]
about this debt but that's also at a
time where they used to work together
they don't work together today back then
they used to you know go and say hey
need your help man let's figure this out
I'll give you this you give me this if
have you guys ever read the book um uh
Tip O'Neill not Tip O'Neill it's another
book about Reagan the the guy who was
this right-hand Guy what's his name oh
um
no no no he was like the chief of staff
he was an absolute Beastie guy or James
Brady James yeah so Jim Baker's book
it's like 1500 pages man it's it's a
long book but if you ever read it you
will see how many times Reagan went
across the aisle and said hey can we
let's figure out a way to negotiate and
see what we can do about this here's my
opinions on this Tyler okay the issue
with this getting fixed is our current
election system and and what I mean by
the election system is the following
thing or whatever way you elect your uh
uh your candidates or your politicians
everybody today benefits from giving
things away for free
and because the system is in a way where
you have to get reelected every four
years the right person and the right
policies to fix this would never get
elected today so so in order for this to
get fixed you need you need 20 years of
President House and Senate to all be
bought into paying off the national debt
to even address this issue it's not
going to happen because those policies
will never get somebody to say oh so
what we need to do is stop spending what
we need to do is keep a reasonable
interest rate up and what we need to do
is stop trying to chase all these other
things for how long 20 years I'm all in
let's go do it and pay off our debt
people aren't going to buy into that not
to mention who are the people that were
electing into Congress now the future
generation is a generation built on the
idea that that you have to go into
massive amounts of debt to make any
money right the college student like
look at AOC how much debt was seen
before we elected her to Congress this
this is what she's built her foundation
on is debt right so we have to have a
Groundswell a a cultural change wherein
people not just the government people as
themselves we have to stop this idea you
know how dramatic that dramatic of a
philosophy that is look you know who
benefits long term think about it this
way Elon Musk gets 180 million dollars
FDC sells PayPal we just talked about a
couple weeks ago he sells PayPal gets
180 million he chooses to put 100
million dollars into SpaceX he chooses
to put 70 million dollars into Tesla he
chooses to put 10 million dollars into
the solar business that he has fast
forward later today's Worth to 200
billion dollars one day he's worth 300
billion one day he's worth 150 billion
give or take he's worth 150 to 300
billion dollars but he can say I'll buy
Twitter for 44 billion and he can go out
there and say I'm buying the company I'm
going to figure out a way to buy it
right why did he do that he's a
long-term thinker he's a long-term
thinker we have become such short-term
thinkers that we just want to elect
somebody that can solve our problems now
I want to drink a you know drink that's
going to make me lose 10 pounds for
tomorrow's party now I want to take
something in my body that my muscles are
going to be 18 guns now I want to buy a
Bitcoin that's going to help me become a
millionaire now everything is this now
mentality and unfortunately we vote with
now mentality we buy with now mentality
we sell with now mentality we build with
now mentality no one's thinking about
delayed gratification order your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]